we're asked to simplify log base 5 of 25
to the x power
over
y so we can use some logarithm
properties and i do agree that this does
require some simplification over here
that this having this right over here
inside of the logarithm is not a
pleasant thing to look at so the first
thing that we realize and this is the
logarithm one of our logarithm
properties is logarithm for a given base
so let's say that the base is x of a
over b that is equal to log base x of a
minus log base x of b and here we have
25 to the x over y so we can simplify so
let me write this down i'll do this in
blue
log base 5 of 25 to the x over y
using this property means that it's the
same thing as log base 5 of 25 to the x
power minus
log
base 5 of y
now
this looks like we can do a little bit
of simplifying and it seems like the
relevant logarithm property here is if i
have log base x of a to the b power
that's the same thing as b times log
base x of a that this exponent over here
can go be moved out front which is what
we did right over there so this part
right over here can be rewritten as
x
times the logarithm
base 5
of 25 and then of course we have minus
log
base 5 of y
and this is useful because log base 5 of
25 is actually fairly easy to think
about this part right here is asking us
what power do i have to raise 5 to to
get to 25 so we have to raise 5 to the
second power to get to 25 so this
simplifies to 2. so then we are left
with this is equal to
2 and i'll write it in front of the x
now 2 times x
2 times x
minus
minus log
base 5 of y and we're done